Yle Areena.
(Musiikkia)
No hei! Mä oon vuosikaudet ihmetyttänyt tämmönen sanakuun "lettu". Mikä se on? Elikä mun mielestä se on ohukainen tai räiskäle, viipuen koos.
Ja kun on tietysti päämurinpohjanopainen niin "lettu" on tullut se on jopa noissa ruokaohjeissa. Kei "lettuja". Mun mielestä se on karvee sana "lettu". Pirkko Tampereen Tammelassa, moro.
Jaks on matkaappana mielipiteiden viidakossa toimii Koiviston Lauri. Yksi kansalainen haluaa Suomeen koulupakon. Toinen ehdottaa, että tullin takavarikoimat viinat voisi laittaa linnanjuhulien Booliin. Ja kaupunkien keskustoissa pitäisi olla enemmän kukkaniittyjä. Aloitimme ruoka-asialla. Nyt on vuorossa Juoma Puolta.
Tää on niin juuri, että nuoret ovat väseneet, kun he menevät armeijaan. Mutta kun nyt nuoriutta viedään jo energiajuoma, ettei ole kahdeksantoista vuotiaita, ettei voi ottaa energiajuoma, niin millä voimalla te ihminen on? Siitä kummallinen otus, että se vaatii ravintoon, ihan kunnon kävintoon. Ja kun tättiä sanoo kunnon aamupala energiajuomansa, mistä sen ottaa, jos rahaa ei ole?
Ja työt ei ole ja asut löytyy ja vaatettakin löytyy ja... - Hetkinen siis mitä mieltä olet että pitääkö energiahuomat kieltä alle 20-vuotiailta vai ei? - Ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei
Suomessa on nykyisin suuria uhkia ja vaaratilanteita. Suomessa on jälleen selvitelty omia ja tulos on selvillä. Suivirren esittäminen on niin uhkaava asia, että koulujen pitää lähettää koteihin vaaratiedote, jos Suivirsi aiotaan laulaa.
Tällä tavoin luki kortissa, jonka meille on lähettänyt nimenomaan, onko järjenkäyttö kielletty. Kansanradioon voi lähettää kortteja ja muuta perinteistä postiaosoitteeseen. Kansanradio pl79 000 24 Yleisradio.
Niinku keskustelu, että järkyttälään sellaista voidaan uhata edes sakolla, koska eihän se ole mitään rikollista. Siinähän kaikissa virsit tää on uskollisuutta. Mutta se, että tää on niin perinteinen juttu, että ettei nyt tällaisesta pidä niinku sakolla uhata. Se on ihan niinku lapsellista pelleilyä. Ja jokainen koulu voi tehdä itse oma päätöksensä asiasta. Ja toivottavasti.
Laulalaitteen joo katela maimoi. No ei tästä Suvivirrestä kun norjisevat jotkut, niin miksi ei voisi Suvivirren tilalle panna tätä Lordin Harcrot hallujaa? Sehän olisi ihan mahtava juttu. Sehän varmaan koululaiset hurrais. Herkka Itä Suomesta. Minä olen viime kertaisen soittijan kanssa sama.
Ja kouluun kuuluu päättäjäis virsi. Mun aikana oli kans kuuskut luvulla ja meidän lapsilla oli myös. Kiitos.
Hallituksissa ja radioissa niin aivan kohtuuttomasti. Ennen vanhaan oli todella hyviä, kauniita, sanotettuja lauluja ja hienoa musiikkia, mutta nyt se on semmosta hirveätä remua, mistä musiikki ei ole enää vähäkään kohtuudessa laulua, joka ei ole kuullut takaa ensinkään. Laulun sanat ovat monta kertaa samojen sanojen pystymistä vähän väljään. Niistä puuttui se juoni ja todellinen laulun sanoma, että tässä on kyllä korjaamisen varaa, muuten todella runsaasti. Monet asiat ennen vanhaan oli selvästi paremmin, ei kaikki, mutta monet asiat.
Voi paremmin kuin nykyisin. Nyt minä soittelen tässä Suvivirrestä. Kansalaiset ovat käsittäneet väärin. Soitetaan kiellettä. Eihän se ole kielletty ollenkaan Suivirin soittaa, vaan siitä on ilmoitettava etukäteen siellä luokassa tai siellä opettajien ilmoittaa, että täällä soitetaan Suivirsi. Jos haluavat jotkut poistua, niin voi poistua sieltä. Se on näin yksinkertainen asia. Ahaa.
Ei ole mitään ongelmaa. No ei varmaa ole, vaan siinä on virhettapahtuna siinä, että jos ei ole nämä opettajat tai nämä ovat ilmoittaneet etukäteen, että Suivirsi lauletaan siinä tilaisuudessa. Semmoiset, jotka eivät halua kuulla sitä, niin tietenkin voivat poistua sieltä. Tässä olisi kyllä pitänyt koulujen olla sinun yhteydessä, niin tässä olisi säästytty aika isolta asialta. Nimenomaan. Mutta onneksi sinä nyt soitit tätä kerroittavan. Minä aapä kerroittavan. Minä kuuntelin tänään tuo kansainvälisyys.
Tulee muuten komaita linnunlaulua sieltä taustalta. Kiitoksia tästä soitosta ja oikein hyvää kesäpäivän jatkoa. Kiitos, oli samoin, heippa.
liippaaviin ajatuksiin? - Ei. Suomeen pitää saada koulupakko. Ei maahanmuuttajat ikinä kotiudu Suomeen, jos ei ja opi Suomen tavoille. Tää on kyllä väärin, että on tämmöinen tullu. Matkitaan kerrankin niin kuin Ruotsissa, eikä voitakaan tuomoisia tekemään, että sitten tulee sitä kaikkea rikollisuutta, kun eivät tiedä miten Suomessa toimitaan. Siis koulupakko.
- Suomeen aikille. - Toista Lappeenrammasta kuuntelin sen ohjelman siitä, mitä sieltä valitettiin, mutta vielä niitä hölmöilyjä on muutakin. Siinä kun ajattelee Lappera keskustan kaikkein kalleimmalla paikalle siitä, meinataan LUT-yliopistolle antaa opiskelija-asunto -tontti omaksi. Myydään niin sille, mikä siitä tulee isosta opiskelijatiedostalosta.
Siitä tulee keskustan häiriöpaikka. Niillä on juhlaa, on kaikennäköistä. Tiedän sen jo siellä Kinnarilan asuntoalueella. Sen juhlinnan, mitä siellä on. Ne temput, mitä siellä tehty. Yksiön saunaan on tehty keittiön vilttystä ovi, istuttu tiskipöydillä, heitetty hellalle löylyä. No, kaupungilla tuli kohtalainen lasku tästä joitakin joitakin vuosia sitten.
Ja sitten se keskusta. Se on ihan mahalton. Sinne pitäisi tulla kuvaajan kuvaamaan, miten se on räjähtänyt, kun kaikki on muuttunut pois, ikkunoita potkittu. On kusi paikkoja, haisee joka paikassa. Ja sitten suunnitellaan kaikilla asuntoalueilla, saaristoon ja muuta. Jotenkin tuntuu, että jo kaikki kohdallaan. Ei muuta.
toteaa täällä Raatu Rihellinen.
Rajan on 60 vuotta ja läkkiästä leikattaisiin niin paljon, että vanhuksilla ei olisi rahaa ostaa kautta ylläpitää mitään sosiaalisen median välineitä, niin eivät hekään olisi sielläkään vaikuttaa. Kiitos.
Tui nimittäin niin, että grillin takaa tuli liekit ja talon seinämeenä syttyi tuleen. Jos en olisi ollut grillin vieressä sammuttamassa grilliä ja vetämässä sitä pois seinän vierestä, olisi tulipalo tuhonnut talon. Olen ihmeessäni, kuinka noin vaarallinen homma on sallittu kerrostalossa. Hyvää ja turvallista kesä ja kaikille kuuntelijoille.
Jollaisia muuten on mukana useampikin tässä ohjelmassa. Kansanradion WhatsApp numero on 044 551 5464.
Jos hän sanoo, että se mies esitteli talouden hoitaa, mutta se voi olla ihan noin vitsikin tai niin kuin sitä edes, että minä olen taloudenhoitaja.
No kuulostaako se vitsiltä? Ei, mutta monet voivat käyttää sitä. Onko se teillä Turussa päin tapana tämmöinen vitsi, koska hänhän puhuu Turusta olevasta miehestä.
Että itsekin on taloushommat hoitunut. Kyllä ja sitten monta kertaa se on naisen vikaan, kun hän ei ole antanut miehen tehrää. Hän on tehnyt kaikki itse ja sitten jos hän nainen lähtee viedä, niin se mies on ihan tumpelo.
Niin, että naiset ovat kieltäneet miehiltä taloushommien hoidon. Niin, niin. Niin on kaikki tiedon monta. Tai Simo tuo, että ei ole antanut tehrät. Nainen tekee kaiken ja jos hän lähtee rinnalla, niin se mies on.
Ihan tumpelo ei olisi edes unikeyttä tuota noin ja ei sen ihan pidä paikkaiseksi. No mitä tälle voitaisiin mielessäni tehdä, että naiset eivät kieltäisi miehiltä taloushommien hoitoa? Niin antaisi miehen tehrää. Monta kertaa miehet tulisivat siihen ja jos jotain pyykkii, koneeseen laittaa ja et antaisi sen tehrää. Mut ei kun vaan tee itse kun sen muuten kuin se ollaan. Niin kiitoksia tästä näkökulmasta. Ole hyvä. Hyvää suntaan jatkoa. Samoin.
Ei. No lasi tältä Helsinki Alppiläilystä päivää päivä päivää. No minulla on vähän kommentoitavaa naiselle kun hän päitteetä miehen kaipaavaan vaimoa. Minulla on kakskymmentäneljä vuotta siitä kun oli sellainen naisystävä. Minä tein hänelle aamiaisen ja hän teki päivällisen. Ja sitten kun hän kuoli yllättäen, niin tuli sellaisia naisystäviä, jotka halusi vain rakastella. Ja minä olin.
Olen ollut neljätoista vuotias kun äikin kuoli yllättäen ja sitten meillä oli kaksi ja puoli vuotta korihoitaja. Hän sanoi että jonkun täytyy tehdä edes ruoka osalta laittaa kun hän tiesi että minä olin innokas kokkaamaan niin hän sanoi että kuorossa lasi saa laittaa ruokaa. Pikkuhiljaa meni kaikki muullakin. Laatteittenpäsut ja sitten parhaimmillaan tein vielä tietoja kun minä tiedän että minä en ole ainoa sellainen mies joka tekee näin. Minä olin Vaasassa aikoinaan ilmaston tilaisen.
Tää kurssilla niin siellä on kaveri. Myöhemmin minä näin hänet täällä Helsinkiin. Hän sanoi että hän on ravintoassa kokkina. Kyllä miehet osaa kokoata ja laittaa kaiken laittaa mutta tällöin naiset on vaan ikävä kyllä käynyt se verran huonon tuuri ettei hän ole koodannut sellaista miehistä.
Selvä. Kiitoksia paljon Lassi näistä ajatuksista.
No olkaa hyvä ja työn illa ja sen suomaisi unelta. Kiitos. Hei hei kun taas on aika auringon lauletaan laurussa. Nyt on kuitenkin paikallaan nauttia tämänkertainen annos kotimaan politiikkaa.
Tarvitas terve toivottavasti semmoista asiaa että kun näitä puolueitten kannatusjuttuja tulee joka päivä monta kertaa päivässä ja taas seuraavana päivänä samat jutut niitä niin ketä tämmöinen kiinnostaa. Eikö tämmöisen systeemin voisi olla että eduskuntavalleihin on melkein vuosiaikaa että kuukautta aiemmin näitä ruvettaisiin julkistamaan. Ketä tämmöinen niin sanottu palkka jahminen kiinnostaa. Etukäteen niiden. No niin. Moi.
Solli kovasti pelottaa että ihmiset ei tajua että miten syvässä suossa me ollaan Suomen valta. Minä koetan selvittää. Viime vuonna kaksituhatta kakskymmentäviisi valtio otti lisää velkaa siis nettovelkaa lisää seitsemäntoista miljardia vähän ennen. Se on joka päivä nelkytviisi miljoona eli jokainen suomalainen mummovaari Natiauset just syntyneet työssä käyvät työttömät yheksän euroa. Joka ainokainen päivä otetaan velkaa. Tämä maa pyö. Jos mä näytän.
Toisinpäin. Viime vuonna kaksituhatta kaksikymmentäviisi synty nelkytviisit viisituhatta lasta. Tarkoittaatteko tuo velka jaetaan näille syntyneille lapsille. Se oli kolmasataa seitsemänkymmentäseitsemän tuhatta euroa. Eli onko nyt ihan oikeasti reilua että me ylläpidetään semmoista elintasoa mihin meillä ei ole varaa. Todetaan että tulevaisuudessa lapset maksavat. Kiitos. Ei.
Voi. Voisiko se nyt parempi kun virkamiehet alkaisivat hoitaa näitä Suomea asioita että ei tämä etuuskunta eikä hallitus pysty enää mihinkään. Kiistelevät vaan keskenään virkamiehille valta.
Teetäis näin, tulis varmaan huomautus ja eikä potkut. Toinen asia, kun tuli takavarikon näitä viinoja, niin olisi hyvä käyttää tuolla itsenäisyyspäivän juhlissa ja tooliin, eikä kaataa vienareita. Ja kun juhlat loppuu, niin televisioita ja haastateta näitä kansanedustajia, niin olisi kansalaisillakin hauskaa leikkaa näin. Ei muuten kuin hyvää jatkoa. Heipparallaa!
Nimittäin tähän: "Minulla ei muuta asiaa ole, mutta kun ei tuossa Kansanradiossa sanota, milloin se tulee se ohjelma uusintana, se minä haluaisin tietää. Kiitos, hei!"
Ja nyt sen saat tietää. Kansanradio tulee radiossa sunnuntain puolenpäivän lisäksi myös perjantain ja lauantain välisinä yönä kello 2.15, mikäpä sen parempaa kuunneltavaa kesäyössä.
Tälläkin kertaa soteteemoista löytyy ajatuksia ja niiden vuoro on nyt.
Nahdoton meininki, eikä sitä mitään säästöä tulee. Päinvastoin eikä koko sote sika tulee mitään säästöä. Alun perinhän tämä sote piti olla, kun se laitettiin Kataisen tubiin ja sitten Petteri Orpon hänne keksittämään alkuperäisesti tämän sote homman, että soteista pitää saada säästöä. Siis kaikista sosiaalimenoista, mutta kun tämä nykyinen hallitus aloitti tämä toinen, niin eihän edes rahoitusta ollut. Silloin se edellinen hallitus tätä.
Edellinen hallitus ei ollut edes putkitoinut rahaa tähän, niin nyt tämä sote pyörii koko ajan velkarahalia. Niin tää on aivan ihan käsittämätön asia. Niin tämmöinen on ja olisi kyllä paljon muutakin sanottavaa, mutta tällä kertaa nyt tämä. Kiitos. Hei!
Junot purkautuu sinne, tämmöistä asiaa vain täältä. Hei hei!
Miksi sairaalat suljetaan ja viettään työttömänä ihmisiä, maksaa se sekin yhteiskunnalle? Ja mitä maksaa tämä Kela-taksi juttu? Ja sitten nämä Kela-taksit on niin valtansa voima Suomessa, että sitten ne ottaa ne pitemmän matkan ajelut ensiksi. Ja sitten nämä kilometrimatkat voi jopa neljä tuntia ottaa potilaspyytiä. Että jonkunlaiseen hallintaan ruetkee hyvää Kela-laskemaa. Mikä onko hallinta, että on paikallinen sairaala ja paikallinen sairaala?
lääkärit ja hoitajat ja työtä ja radaa kiertäisiin. Tämä on ihan hävittömyyden huippu ja meitä vanhoja ihmisiä kahdeksankymppisiä viskellään puolilta toiselle sairaaloihin tuntemattomiin paikkoihin. Kiitos.
Heippa täältä keskisiomasta tämmöinen nuori soittelee vaan tämmöistä asiaa että tää on ihan naurettava että täältä keskitetään joka ikinen vuodeosastot lopetetaan kaikki keskitetään tuonne Jyväskylään ja säästöjen takia ei täällä tule mitään säästöjä. Omaiset joutuu mennä pitkin ja potilaita viidät ympäri maakuntia että ei tässä ole mitään järkeä.
toiset ammat emme ole ylläpitäisiä verkkojen toiset ammat mutta minä en ymmärrä minkä takia seitsemänkymppiselle ikäiselle vanhuksille antaa samat lääkkeet kuin kolmekymmentävuotiaille. Minä en ymmärrä miksi vanhuksille antaa samat lääkkeet kuin keski ikäiselle ihmiselle kun ei niiden elimistöä kestä. Se on fysiologien juttu. Anteeksi minä en ymmärrä miksi vanhuksille antaa samat lääkkeet kun niiden elimistöä kestää.
Nyt siirrymme luontoa koskeviin kannanottoihin. Ennen niitä on paikallaan muistuttaa että kansanradion jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan joka perjantai kello kaksikymmentäyksi. Jos merkkaat sydämen kuvasta ja tilat ohjelmasta ilmoitukset kellon kuvasta niin saat aina ensimmäisenä tiedon kun uusi jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan.
että ne pitäisi poistaa järvien reunoilta. Eihän sehän hienampaa kukkasta ole olemassakaan niitä.
Mikä näitä viherpiipertajia vaivaa? Sama asia on tuota noita, niin nyt jos omokotitalon pihalla on näitä tiettyjä kasveja, nehan on ollut vuodet siellä sitten niitä. Eikä ne ole ketään haittaneet.
Kyllä tämä viherpiipertajien touhun nyt menee kyllä niin yli tai on mennyt jo ajat sitten, että eihän tässä ole mitään järkeä niitten. Pitääkööt itse oman pihansa minkälaisessa kunnossa hyvänsä ja antakoon lupiinäitten olla se on kaunis kukkanen tuolla järvien reunoilla. No niin, kiitos, hei hei.
Kiitos tietävästä vastauselta. Hei hei. - Näytä Tamminen Lempelästä huomenta. Mitä mieltä olet? Olivatko esi-isät järkevämpiä kuin nykyiset ihmiset? Kyllä olivat, koska he hyväksivät tänne vierasait, kuten viljakasvit, perunat, kaikki uudeksi ynnä muut, omenapuut ja marjapensaat ja kaikkea. Ja nykyihän nämä pykivät jatkuvasti vähentämään kasveja. Kylläkin saattaa olla, että näin monipuolistuu Suomen luonto.
Kun sitä hävitään, nytkin on yli sata kasvia pitkälti. On poistetuta versiaa. Jopa vankeudella uhkata ihmisiä, jotka kasvavat tai jotain kasvoja. Että miten he voisivat tehdä, että nämä, jotka kannattavat tätä niitä kasvien hävitystä, saavat pistää aasinhatuun päihänsä ja mennä nurkkaan häpeämään. Ja jos jukisella paikallaan liikkuu, niin pitäisi ilmoittaa, että sillä hatulla heitä kannattavat kasvien hävitystä. Eipä tässä on muuta, mutta toivon, että Suomen kansa nousee.
Kohtainen viime tukkasi pesästä loppu. No Mika Pehkurini soittaa Joensuusta hyväpäivää. Hyväpäivää. Tuota minä semmoisella asialla lähestysin, kun luonnon monimuotoisuudesta ja pörjäisistä ja kukkaniitystä on ollut juttua tässä muutaman vuoden ajan. Meillä on täällä Joensuussa 1962 Joensuun vanha apteeki, apteekkari Veijo Manneliini on rakennuttanut Taunolaakkosen, joka on autotaloudellinen.
Taunolaakkosen veljestä isäni sen kanssa kerrostaloi ja sen pihassa on Joensuun keskustessa kukkaniity, koska hän kerää sitä apteekkari Veijo Mannelin perhosia, jota oli äärellä kuolleessaan 842 kappaletta. Ja minä olen ja nyt taloudellisesti jo asukkaatin viisitoista vuotta sitten elvytetty tätä kukkaniityä. Nyt viime syksynä oli sitten perusteellisemmat alkuotetta, että eka kerta ostettiin tämmöisiä kukkaniityn siemeniä ja pistettiin multaa kolmesenkymmentä säkkiä.
Eli ymmärsinkö oikein, että mielipiteisi on se, että kaupunkiojen keskustalueille tarvittaisiin enemmän kukkaniittyjä?
Joo, kyllä. Että ne on mannerikäätikin muodostamia, kivijä multamaan ja sitten tämmöisiä ikihongia, että se rohalla leikkulit vaan mustalla mullalla. Sen aina laittos sen piene alueen. Sitten ne autot oli Luiskassakin. Nyt siellä oli jo ne alkuperäiset. Taivan kakkarat oli hyvällä nupulla ja tissan kellot kukkia.
Ja se on nimenomaan se niiden pörjäisten näkökulma, joka näitä pörjästi. Ja sitten onhan se kaunis katseltuva luonnonkukka, että aivan. Tällä viikolla me laitettiin kahdeksan säkkiä multaa ja sitten tuomaan tuon kehäkukan siemeniä ja sitten tarvitsin mehiläiskukkaa, sinisievikkiä ja olkikukkaa. Ne on nyt tarkoitusta sitten ainakin tänä kesänä kukkisia. Sitten viime syksänä panttiin semmoisia, että ne olisivat monivuotisia. Kiitoksia paljon tästä mielenkiintoista uudestaan.
Kiitoksia tästä uudesta ehdotuksesta ja oikea hyvää pyhäpäivän jatkoa. Hei hei. Kiitos. Hei hei. Kukkaniityltä kirmaamme televisio- tai radiota koskeviin puheluihin. Niitä ennen kerron vielä Kansanradion puhelinnumeron. Se on 08 001 5564 ja puhelu on soittaajalle maksuton. Ja muistutuksena, että sunnuntaisin kello kaksitoista kolmekymmentä alkaen tuossa.
Kansanumerossa vastaa ihmis vastaa ja kolmen tunnin ajan. Hyvää päivää Kansanradio. Täällä on Terttu, joka on Karjalan evakon jälkeläinen. Äiti oli tämä henkilö ja isä oli puolustusvoimien palveluksessa lähes koko ikänsä. Vielä eläkepäivinäkin. Mutta minä haluan kiittää Yleisradioa tästä lauantaina olevasta ohjelmasta, jonka taas tänä aamuna kuuntelin. Tämä lehmityttöjä. Tämä ohjelma. Tämä oli.
Niin hyvä ohjelma, että kannattaa sit jossain vaiheessa myös laittaa se uusiksi. Minä olen kiinnostunut kaikista näistä asioista, mitä Suomessa yleensä tapahtuu sekä kansan kohtaloista että nykypäivästä, että kun olen entinen yksityisyrittäjä, että kiitos Yleisradiolle. Kiitos paljon. Hei.
Täällä yksi äijä Helsingistä puhuu, että kun katsoo television kanavia, niin on tomonta. Mutta eikö siellä yleensä tai missään osata kääntää niitä ohjelman nimiä Suomessa?
Kattoa ikkosta, kakkosta, kolmosta, vitosta, seiskaa tai mitä tahansa. Niin siis aina englanninkieliset tai joku muukieliset. Siinä on ohjelman nimi. Mikä se on? Ihminen ei tiedä. Ei mulla semmoista telkkää.
Vapaapaivaininfo, siihen tuli se sama nimi sille elokuvalle. Enkä mä tiedä ollenkaan, mitä se tarkottaa, mistä se kertoo. Että semmoinen olisi hyvä, jos siellä joku osaa vielä kääntää ne Suomessa ne nimet. Mikä murhaelokuva on kysymyksessä tai mikä vaan, niin se olisi hieno juttu. Kiitos.
Kun se on käynyt, niin jotenkin suuri osa lapsuudestani ja nuoruudestani se meni hirveen syvälle, koska hän edusti turvallisuutta ja tämmöistä uskottavuutta. Kiitos ohjelmasta.
Ei auta, vaikka yrität vähän viestittää, että voimat eivät riitä ja maksimissaan yksi yö. Mukana ei ole lakanoita ja tulijaisena ehkä kahvipaketti.
Mutta yöpyminen on eri asia. Näin lukee sähköpostissa, jonka on lähettänyt esimerkki Mummeli. Kansanradion sähköpostiosoite on kansan.radio.yle.fi.
Hyvää tekeminen kannattaa mennä papin eteen. Kesä myös rikkautta kerää. Eniten ruohoa tällä erää. Vihreätä kultaa paljon saa kun löytyy vettä ja multa. Lehmät tiitä maidoksi saa näin halvalla ansaitaan. Tuhannet järvet paljon antaa. Kaloja saa aika paljon kantaa.
Mukavaa tekemistä saunassa löylyn heittämistä. Uiminen erittäin hyvä tekee. Myös sukeltaminen veteen. Suuret kiitokset kaikille ja hyvää kesää.
wille sitten tehdään mansikkakakkoa ja sillia syödään perunoitten kanssa. Saunotaan kunnolla vihdalla ja nautitaan löylyistä. Tämä juhla on niin ihana, että tällöin tehdään taikoja ja sitä sulhasen löytämiseen. Kesästä nautitaan ja tietysti juhannuksena on tanssin. Kesäilman tanssia ei ole kesä. Nauditaan juhannuksesta, kun kerran tällainen juhla on olemassa.
Olavi soittelee hyvää päivää runokesälle. Aika suven ja keskikesän onan juhla on juhannus. Liput tangoissa tuulessa hulmuvaa. Kokot niemissä laadissa loimuvaa. Loistaa lämpöä valoaan. Soi järvelle anuri hiljainen. Kesäillan valsi soi kaihoten. Joku soittaa ken taitaa sen. Nauttii ihmiset kesästä kauniista. Nauttii lintujen laulusta.
Nauttii kukkien kauniiden tuoksuista. Niiden väreistä. Loistosta. Lapset rannoilla leikkii ja karkeloi. Heillä kaikilla hauskaa on. Onan kesä on juhannus. Hyvää juhannusta.
- Hyvää tätä päivää Kansanradiolle. Tällä tämmöinen pennitön uneksia mietiskelee. Ei ole rahaa shoppailla eikä viettää hauskaa elämää. Tuli pahan tämmöinen mieleen matemaattinen yhtälö. X kertaa, X on X toiseen. Toimiiko se tässä yhtälössä, kun Suomi on maailman onnellisin kansa? Mutta täällä käytetään huumeita, viinoa, mielialaa, masennuslääkkeitä pilviin pimein. Ihmiset on turutettu näillä myrkyillä sompeiksi. Osakoneolla oikein.
enä onnellisia. Ja sitten tämä itsensä rehvastelu, että kun ollaan iloisesti ja onnellisesti ylpeitä omasta itsestään, mistä sitä ollaan onnellisia ja iloisia ja ylpeitä? Minä en oikein ymmärrä. Toimiko tämä matemaattinen lause? Eipäpä tässä mitään muuta kuin voisiko sanoa, että tyhjät tynnyrit kolisivat eniten. Jääpä tätä miettimään, mitä tästä seuraa. Kiitos kaikille, hei!
Sontatunkio on polokia. Niitä pidetään kuninkahana. Ei minkään muissa tolokkuvaa ole. Sitten ne on juhlii ja kaikki paikat ne särköö, kun niiden kannattajat oikein juhlii. Emääkää siitä tuollaista juhlimista. Mantaki piti olla läkkin pistää, jottei ne särje sitten. Sen pitäisi kieltää koko jääkiekon. Ei muuta. Moi.
pitää mennä mökille kun tulee kesäloma ja sitten vielä vanhemmillaan töitä niin että lapset jää kofokesäksi meräntymään kotiin niin että voisi säätää lain ettei saa käydä töissä viikkoon niin olis sitten perheaikaa. Heippa!